of course uh andy always good to have
you here thank you it's always good to
be here
amongst the cardboard and um you know i
got to say
i don't know about you i'm still waiting
on my vaccine yeah i'm still waiting for
them to
announce my category and we've talked
about this before randy but they have
not yet
announced my category do you know what
that category is andy what's that
category conan
national treasure
andy you're in there too in national
treasure oh i am yeah
yeah but i mean well you'd be like a you
know like a
like a big gold statue and i'd be like
an earring
don't put yourself down i'm i like
earrings
i know we're not talking about that
right now
what we're talking about is we just have
to wait our turn
but very excited to get vaccinated once
it's our
turn absolutely and just hoping that at
some point
i will look at the news and they will
say
we now have shots for what well
what i like to call the old nt nt conan
yeah national treasure
any hoots i just imagine your children
being
wake awoken to that that you screaming
at them
national treasure my children moved out
four years ago oh
because i was screaming national
treasure just randomly in the house
and they they actually uh they packed
their bags little suitcases and they
left
they've become quite successful on wall
street